so what would actually happen if you
completely gave up sugar
for two weeks let's Dive Right In the
first thing you would notice is the
shape of your face would change it would
go from being more roundish or puffy to
a inner face like even with my face you
can see this before and after my face
actually was roundish and now it's not
so you'll see it in your face and you'll
definitely see it in your midsection so
the reason why you lose fat in the
midsection is because your liver is
releasing fat when you cut out sugar the
body is now forced to live off fat fuel
because sugar in fat fuel are the only
two fuel sources in the body and given
the choice the body always will burn
sugar over fat when you cut that Sugar
out you're left only with the fat fuel
portion your body to use up the fat
reserves starting with your liver all
right the second thing that's going to
happen there's four main organs that are
going to be affected when you cut out
sugar more than other organs okay your
eyes are definitely going to prove
you'll have less blurriness you'll see
better you you see the eyes are very
sensitive to Sugar this is why diabetics
develop a condition called diabetic
retinopathy okay destruction of the
retina that's the main nerve in the back
of the eye so your eyes will improve the
kidneys will improve the kidney is
another organ that gets hammered with
too much sugar this is why you might end
up with sugar in the urine or protein
urine because the sugar is creating a
lot of inflammation and kind of rusting
out that pipes like your blood vessels
that go right through the kidney it
could be filtered and this is what is
called a diabetic nephropathy Neff
meaning nephron which is the little
filtering things in your kidney so
basically you have better kidney
function and then we have your arteries
if there's too much sugar they call that
diabetic artery disease or vascular
disease and so when you cut the sugar
out the inflammation in your arteries
all that rusting effect Violet excess
glucose will kind of start healing again
and because sugar not only converts the
fat but cholesterol too you'll see your
cholesterol values improve dramatically
then we get to the nerves in the brain
when you decrease sugar out of your diet
your nerves start healing up if you have
a diabetic condition called peripheral
neuropathy where the ends of your nerves
in the bottom of your feet are being
destroyed that will start going away but
also since there's a lot of nerves in
your brain your brain starts healing and
there's two main things in the brain
that will improve first the cognitive
function so your memory is better your
focus is better and your concentration
is much better you're going to find that
your mood is just completely changed
you're going to be much happier
mind-blowing to me and I'm trying to
understand this like diabetes for
example right what is diabetes that is a
disease of too much sugar in your blood
right the obvious approach would be to
eat less sugar if you're diabetic right
I mean if diabetes is too much sugar in
the blood
why not decrease the sugar in your blood
but maybe I'm missing something because
if you look this up medically you look
at what causes diabetes they're going to
say two things lifestyle and genetics
okay and with lifestyle they say it
could be obesity it could be a lack of
exercise or and this is a good one
urbanization okay I guess moving to the
city will increase your risk when
becoming a diabetic but they're not
mentioning too much dietary sugar it's
just wild to me instead they say it's
eating too much saturated fat
but that data has been completely
debunked and I will put a video a couple
things down below you can check out if
you still have even a hint of thought
that it's a saturated fat it's not it's
the carbs and then when you dig a little
bit further regarding the poor diet they
actually tell you to maintain high
levels of grains in your diet now they
will say whole grains but even whole
grains are like 85 percent carbohydrates
maybe you can help me out I don't know
if it's just obvious to me or why other
people are not getting this but it's
just so simple you cut the sugar out if
you have diabetes all right the next
thing you're going to notice is you're
going to get up a lot less during the
night to pee okay why is that because
water follows sugar okay so if you're
eating sugar and it's going to your
blood and it's getting filtered through
the kidney you're going to find them
that's going to trigger more urination
especially at night and one simple
solution is just to start cutting out
the sugar and you will find you're going
to get up a lot less during the night I
mean when I was in practice I'd had
people get up 10 times a night with Pete
and all we did was cut the sugar out and
they slept through the entire night now
it does take a few weeks but to salvage
your sleep is so important all right the
next thing that's going to improve is
your energy well like I said before
there's two types of fuel you can run
your body on sugar and fat when you give
up the sugar your body is forced to burn
your fat well guess what your body has a
lot more calories from fat than sugar
I'm talking about stored sugar and
stored fat on average even a thin person
is carrying around about a hundred
thousand calories of fat compared to
like 1700 calories of stored sugar so if
we were to give you an analogy it would
be like having this huge car battery to
run on versus this little AAA battery if
you're going to run your entire body on
this little AAA Battery you're going to
be constantly hungry craving ups and
down with your energy but when you're
burning fat you no longer are
susceptible to the ups and downs of this
sugar and especially the ups and downs
of this energy fatigue cycle I mean
think about this between the meals right
your body should live on fat an average
person with the standard American diet
cannot even tap into the fat because
there's too much sugar in the
bloodstream so by dropping the sugar
converting your body over to Fat fuel
you are going to be running on fat
constantly between eating as well as
your fat when you eat and so that's
going to give you a tremendous amount of
steady state energy through the whole
day and your brain is going to feel a
lot better and this relates to the next
Point Cravings the reason why your
appetite goes away between meals is
because even though you're not eating
anything okay your body is eating its
own fat between the meals so if it's
eating between the meals it's being
satisfied and you're not going to be
hungry and the only way to achieve that
is by cutting down your sugar as well as
not eating so frequently like all those
snacks so how do you get rid of the
cravings for Sugar by not eating sugar
this process takes about three days and
it's not that hard anyone can do this
you just have to bite the bullet and
jump right in but you want to reduce
your carbs less than 50 grams per day
and that includes the fruits it includes
honey and a lot of the other hidden
sugars as other carbs approach like the
bread pasta cereal crackers biscuits
waffles things like that I mean an
average person at least in the U.S
consumes on average about 13.5 teaspoons
of added sugar every single day that
comes out to 54 grams of sugar for those
of you in Europe now that's added sugar
what about the sugar in the other carbs
like the bread pasta cereal crackers
biscuits waffles pancakes muffins
alcoholic beverages like wine and beer
and and sodas and the juices
Etc that comes out to about a half a
pound of actual sugar every single day
that's 275 grams of sugar that's
68.75 teaspoons of sugar
so this added sugar thing is just the
tip of the iceberg it's all these other
carbs that turn into sugar that is
making a huge problem for your body so
this is why when you make this change
and you start switching the fat burning
you start feeling so good I mean just
the improvements in your mood and
cognitive improvements is just going to
be amazing you're just going to feel
really good not to mention look a lot
better with your clothes fitting better
your face not so round and not craving
sugar that's going to be huge now when
you cut out sugar your inflammation pain
and stiffness is going to also improve
your arteries are going to be less stiff
which means your blood pressure is going
to come down tremendously so the need
for medication becomes a lot less and
since anti-inflammatory medications are
so popular nowadays you'll be able to
hopefully come off that medication as
well because your inflammation is going
to come down and I'm talking about
inflammation in the inside of your
tissues inside the arteries inside your
eyes inside your kidneys inside the
nervous system like the stuff that you
can't really see that will improve you
see the inflammation deep inside the
arteries are actually making the artery
walls thicker okay the thicker the walls
the less space you have for blood to
travel and the more susceptible you are
to getting things like clogged arteries
so what you're doing when you're giving
up sugar is you're allowing more blood
flow to get to the tissues all right so
number seven and this is the obvious one
you're going to lose more weight but not
actually just wait
actual fat which would be a really New
Concept for many people now you will
lose a lot of water weight initially
because like I said before wherever
there's glucose I'm talking about stored
glucose it's glycogen you're going to
also store three times the amount of
water so stored sugar is basically a
fluid filled sponge and you'll lose at
least 13 pounds in the first one to two
weeks just by cutting out the sugar and
that's important but the bigger thing is
you actually get to tap into your actual
fat and start losing weight and think
about all the other benefits of just
losing weight and being able to do
something that's effective if you try to
do a diet with too many carbs boy you're
just going uphill not to mention trying
to lose weight with all the cravings and
the hunger it's going to be torture and
impossible to do it any period of time I
mean I think for some people they may
not know this but carbs convert to fat
and cholesterol okay most of the fat in
your liver has came from carbohydrates
and I'm not talking about solid
carbohydrates I'm talking about the
grains the breads the pasta the starch
potatoes Etc all right the next benefit
is your skin
your acne is going to improve your
dermatitis like the red rashes on the
skin will improve because we're
basically dropping inflammation
everywhere including on your skin in
fact that's one of the things that
changes the shape of your face because
there's less inflammation and puffiness
around your eyes on your cheeks and many
people are not connecting the dots that
that puffy face is excessive
carbohydrates and the last benefit and I
really want to explain this okay and I
saved this for the last you are going to
improve
something at the heart of most health
problems that people have and that is
insulin resistance let me explain what
insulin resistance is first of all you
have to realize that insulin is a
hormone triggered by sugar okay and
carbs and so they both kind of go hand
in hand when you increase insulin it's
because of the carbohydrates so when
your body develops a resistance to
anything it's rejecting that thing okay
now you can also have glucose
intolerance which is a form of
resistance right so this is all about
receptors in your body okay when you're
receiving certain things so when you
consume a lot of sugar over time your
body is resisting that and the sugar
does not connect anymore because the
body is putting up a barrier it's
becoming very intolerant same thing with
insulin right if there's too much
insulin that's very very toxic and
dangerous in the body so your body
develops a resistance against it now to
solve this problem our body just
basically makes more instant to
penetrate this resistance this barrier
so we have a situation where we have a
lot of insulin being produced in the
body thus all the extra side effects
that I just mentioned because a lot of
those are not just glucose they're high
insulin as well but also at the cell
level we have this deficiency of insulin
situation which also creates other
problems but eventually what happens is
the pancreas that's pumping out all this
insulin gets so tired it can't
compensate for this barrier or this
resistance so then it gets tired and it
stops producing as much insulin and this
is when you get pre-diabetes and
diabetes no longer compensating for the
situation and so we don't have enough
insulin to push the blood sugar down so
when you have insulin resistance you
basically have a slow metabolism
situation you're going to have this set
point in a certain way that you just
cannot get past let's say it's 160
pounds you can diet you can exercise
your body will not let you get below
that certain weight and this insulin is
needed for other things like the
absorption of potassium the absorption
of magnesium the absorption of vitamin
B1 the absorption of calcium and many
other nutrients like even vitamin D so
by cutting out sugar you improve insulin
resistance and you increase your
absorption of all these nutrients
including amino acids to build proteins
so if you had atrophy before that looks
like cellulite on the your legs or your
butt all of a sudden that starts
improving you get more muscle and you
get a better body shape getting rid of
this insulin resistance problem helps
fatty liver it helps decrease your risk
for heart disease a stroke and even
cancer
so before you add more time to think
about if you should do this I think you
should start immediately and I put up
this very helpful video to show you
exactly where to start check it out it's
right here